Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This project is a collaboration between INRIA
and Facebook AI research and is about pose
estimation.
Pose estimation means that we take an input
photo or in the cooler case, video of people,
and the output should be a description of
their postures.
This is kind of like motion capture for those
amazing movie and computer game animations,
but without the studio and the markers.
This work goes even further and tries to offer
a full 3D reconstruction of the geometry of
the bodies, and it is in fact doing way more
than that as you will see in a minute.
Neural networks are usually great at these
tasks, provided that we have a large number
of training samples to train them.
So, the first step is gathering a large amount
of annotated data.
This means an input photograph of someone,
which is paired up with the correct description
of their posture.
This is what we call one training sample.
This new proposed dataset contains 50 thousand
of these training samples, and using that,
we can proceed to step number two, training
the neural network to perform pose estimation.
But, there is more to this particular work.
Normally, this pose estimation takes place
with a 2D skeleton, which means that most
techniques output a stick figure.
But not in this case, because the dataset
contains segmentations and dense correspondances
between 2D images and 3D models, therefore,
the network is also able to output fully 3D
models.
There are plenty of interesting details shown
in the paper, for instance, since the annotated
ground truth footage in the training set is
created by humans, there is plenty of missing
data that is filled in by using a separate
neural network that is specialized for this
task.
Make sure to have a look at the paper for
more cool details like this.
This all sounds good in theory, but a practical
application has to be robust against occlusions
and rapid changes in posture, and the good
thing is that the authors published plenty
of examples with these that you can see here.
Also, it has to be able to deal with smaller
and bigger scales when people are closer or
further away from the camera.
This is also a challenge.
The algorithm does a really good job at this,
and remember, no markers and studio setup
is required, and everything that you see here
is performed interactively.
The dataset will appear soon and it will be
possible to reuse it for future research works,
so I expect plenty of more collaboration and
followup works for this problem.
We are living amazing times indeed.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!